[Musique]
même si l'exploitation de l'amiante a
cessé en 2012
le passé minier de la ville est
omniprésent 450 millions de tonnes de
résidus ceinturent la ville des résidus
qui au fil du temps ont aussi été
utilisés comme abrasif sur les routes
et comme matériau pour remblayer comment
disposer de ces vestiges la
décontamination a été envisagée y a
personne que les moyens de décontaminer
la région complet l'apu sont d'une sur
l'environnement avec la pression de la
santé publique c'est que d'autres
pensent purge une ville bocket par blocs
est aux frais des contribuables avaient
la tête forme c'est à ce qu'on sait pas
où ça n'a aucun sens
selon le maire de la municipalité la
solution réside dans l'abaissement des
règles et dans l'exploitation de ces
résidus riche en métaux divers et en
magnésium
une manne qui l'évaluent à plusieurs
milliards de dollars
mais l'idée de rebrasser ces résidus et
de les exploiter une seconde fois ne
fait pas l'unanimité la direction
régionale de santé publique rappelle que
l'amiante était cancérigène que ce
brassage la de résidus est ce que ça va
amener multiplier la présence d'amiante
dans l'air la tête faire de une fois
quatre fois
quand est-ce que c'est acceptable pour
les résidents puis quand elle s'allie
plus acceptable parce que furent mesure
qu'on va augmenter la présence dans là
on va augmenter le risque que ce tournoi
de décès par cancer hautement les
citoyens qui sont partagés
c'est ce ça donnerait de l'emploi pour
la santé dans ce débat là dessus que
plus de 150 rondes et autres trolls que
nous ne parlerons bientôt l'achète pour
l'essayer yolande poulain c'est que les
miens n'est pas sans danger elle a perdu
son mari en 2016
à 58 ans il avait travaillé pendant 20
ans dans une mine de la région sur la
conclusion de l'autopsié le décès est
lié à l'amiante
mon mari bande son dont l'un lui a fait
perdre sa vie donc c'est pour ça que
l'amiante
non moi c'est un bannissement les cas de
cancers des travailleurs sont plutôt
bien documentés dans la région mais la
direction de santé publique a peu de
données sur le niveau d'amiante présents
dans l'air de la ville et sur les
impacts sur ses résidents
ce qui fait dire au maire de tête food
qu'ils n'ont pas de données a opposé au
projet de revitalisation des résidus
écoutez la santé publique est plein de
contradictions là-dedans émet des
recommandations qui malheureusement sont
prises comme la parole du pape par
plusieurs ministères et c'est pour ça
que les audiences ont l'eau je pense
qu'on est en train de faire un excellent
travail pour démonter plein de mythe
il ya un risque existe ni connu c'est
très inquiétant même je dirais comme
comme responsables de santé publique
si j'étais un citoyen de la pop et de
téléphone qui résident proche des ald
sharing
mais peu importe la décision le problème
de l'amiante restera entier at it funny
games le maire de la municipalité de 26
mille habitants explique que déjà à
chaque chantier coûte deux fois plus
cher qu'ailleurs en raison des règles
strictes de manipulation des résidus
d'amiante ici ghislaine bussières radio
canada ted friedmann ce